hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update bethesda today confirmed
that the Xbox one and PlayStation 4
versions of their FML Elder Scrolls
online is going to be delayed Bethesda
says they're having a challenging time
integrating their systems with the
different console manufacturers networks
they said we continue to work on the
console versions of ESO and game
development has been progressing
steadily but we're still working to
solve a series of unique problem
specific to those platforms we have
concluded that we'll need about six
months to ensure we deliver the
experience our fans expect and deserve
as one way to lessen the blow Bethesda
will allow fans who have bought the pc
or mac version by the end of june to
transfer their characters to either
console when those versions are released
and that's not all bethesda said you
don't have to pay full price for the
game twice for twenty dollars eligible
pc and mac players will have the option
to add a full digital version of ESO on
either the ps4 or the Xbox one along
with your character transfer and another
30 days of included game time however
that offer is only good until June for
some reason so act fast if you have a
gaming PC then want to pay more to
switch to a console version several
months later if you're still on the
fence about the game be sure to check
out kevin van lords review and for even
more news about elder scrolls online be
sure to check out gamespot com